à quelques heures d'un discours aussi
attendu que critiqué le sujet de la
visite de benyamin nétanyahou au congrès
américain a sans surprise occupé la
majeure partie de ce débat sur la
politique étrangère des différents
partis israéliens
expects israël personne ne peut attendre
d'israël qu'il se taise a déclaré le
candidat du likoud le parti du premier
ministre ce n'est pas sur le fond de la
question qu'on s'en prend ici au
discours du premier ministre sur cette
scène tout le monde s'entend l'iran est
une menace à la survie mal de l'état
hébreu mais à seulement deux semaines
des élections certains y voient un
calcul électoraliste voire opportuniste
qui a fait part le moment monter le
temps
12 mai relève un candidat de l'union
sioniste principal adversaire du likoud
aux élections s'inquiète de la
dégradation des relations entre la
maison blanche et israël tout ça pour
gagner des votes petit yves eric chaque
semaine le likoud descend dans les
sondages et je crois qu'il croit pouvoir
inverser la tendance c'est tout
dans la rue israélienne c'est un
reproche qui est très répandue
aujourd'hui bd re chèvres à cas là tu
mens leurs preuves à la bibine pense
qu'elles lui même dit cette femme qui
l'appelle par son surnom il ne pense à
personne d'autre et c'est très mauvais
si le citoyen israélien était important
pour lui qu'il aurait dû se rendre à
washington après les élections elle
précise n'avoir aucune intention de
regarder le discours
pourtant il était inévitable
diffusé en début de soirée à heure de
grande écoute sur toutes les chaînes de
télé israélienne il a été retransmis
avec un délai de 5 minutes pour
permettre de couper le signal au cas où
le premier ministre fasse référence
directement l'élection israélienne ce
qui aurait été contraire aux règles
électorales dans ce commerce ceux qui se
sont arrêtés pour entendre benyamin
netanyahu croit qu'il a rempli son
devoir de chef d'état on n'a pas le
choix il faut qu'on s'exprime il faut
qu'on reste sage suisse passe exactement
afin que tu flippes qui puisse annuler
ses acolytes se fait passer pour nous
cette cachotterie tri g si si c'est
encore là c'est un grand danger pour
nous malgré son appui lui ne votera pas
pour benyamin netanyahou il lui préfère
un candidat religieux mais l'image du
premier ministre va sillonner à des
dizaines de reprises par le congrès
américain pourrait convaincre certains
électeurs qui hésite entre un désir de
changement et un besoin de sécurité
l'enjeu n'est pas prioritaire pour les
israéliens selon les sondages mais
benyamin nétanyahou espère ramener cette
question qui lui est favorable
en tête de liste pour aujourd'hui en
tout cas c'est un pari qui est gagné si
marié vesdun radio-canada jérusalem